back sources telling fox news just now
that president trump met with potential
supreme court nominee judge amy coney
barrett
at the white house today barrett is
thought to be a
front-runner meantime many on the left
furious with republicans plan to fill
the now vacant supreme court seat
protesters even showing up outside the
homes of senators mitch mcconnell and
lindsey graham
and democrats and some in the media are
ramping up their
rhetoric take a look we need to be
out in the streets we need protests out
there every single day
they are so beneath uh any kind of
shamelessness that it's impossible to
even talk to these people
it is not hyperbole the actual balance
of our democracy
rests in the actions
that we choose to make let this moment
radicalize you all right um
degan if there are calls for more
protests
don't you think that that gives
republicans even more ad fodder
to aim at the suburbs absolutely because
the protests won't be peaceful
they will end up being i mean which is
pointed out they're essentially calling
for unrest in the streets
and these are democrats that could not
condemn
for months violence mayhem
rioting looting and destruction of
people's livelihoods across this country
but now this is okay it would be
laughable if it wasn't so dangerous
and radical she said aoc says you've got
to be radicalized and this is not
hyperbole greg
no no but you know i was laughing at it
but in their
minds it's not hyperbole this is
intimidation and
remember when they go to people's houses
they're not going to intimidate
they're not going to those houses to
intimidate those specific people
that's to intimidate everybody else i'm
doing it
yeah it's basically saying you're next
we're going to do this to mcconnell but
maybe jesse you're going to be next
and this is what this does is it scares
the crap out of people who should be
speaking up
so you're going to see moderate
democrats silent
anchors of tv shows emmy nominees
uh ceos at corporations these are the
people that are always going to be
thinking
you know this crockett crocodile might
eat dagan mcdowell
but that crocodile's not going to eat me
but sooner or later that crocodile eats
everybody
who stays quiet it's uh and and the
worst thing about is you keep hearing
all these people saying burn it down
oh if this nomination happens burn it
down you're saying that after a billion
dollars
of damage was done with businesses and
homes were burned down
no class at all and anything
maybe one last word if the government
doesn't step up and deal with this
violence
it's going to be up to the public
because this is truly taxation without
representation
right if you're not being protected but
you're paying your taxes that second
amendment starts looking
miraculous juan can the democrats take
this energy and turn it into votes for
joe biden
sure i mean look i i don't think you
need aoc
michael moore or anybody else dana to
make this case because people are
so upset over what is taking place this
is an abuse of power
this is breaking down american
institutions no it's not
those this by the way degan they had
they had people protesting as you
said at mcconnell's house at lindsey
graham's i said there's no violence it's
a legitimate protest
why would you not yet let me just i
would not yeah if they went to you
you were trying to make the case pushing
the fare button oh gosh this is going to
result i actually saw what happened in
new york city
in may in june in july and august i've
been attacked
now you're talking about stuff that
doesn't exist and this is my point to
you
there was no violence exist there's no
violence in fact you know today your
neighborhood was looted oh stop look
nice oh yeah oh yeah new york is so
terrible let me just tell you
because you were living in your seat
here right now
i'm gonna walk you down this path
picture there's nobody here that's how
bad the cops look bored that's what's
going on
but my point to you is look 50 percent
jump in murder
right off no no no but let me just say
to your point dana
i don't approve of protest at people's
homes i don't think that's legit
but i do think that when people say
that they are upset here they have a
legitimate right to protest and that's
what you're going to see
all right jesse can you be quick it's
not abuse of power
and if it was impeach them a second time
on my point is this they have to go
crazy because
the judicial branch is almost all the
left has all of their stuff is so
borderline unconstitutional it's so
unpopular they can't get it through the
house the senate they can't get a
president to sign this stuff
they rely on judicial activism
look at pennsylvania you know what they
did dana they said
signatures don't have to match on
ballots so you could have someone with
this beautiful cursive signature
send in something with chicken scratch
in capital letters
and you can't challenge that and then
they said you can send in the ballot it
can come in
three days after the election no postage
and you have to accept that all right we
got a that is